[Music]
it's difficult to believe but you're
looking at a mountain of smoke
yes industry has housekeeping problems
to smoke the product of industry was
collected in special smoke stacks
compressed into pellets like these and
piled here until eight years ago when
this pile was started all of this smoke
was in the air that people were
breathing now for the simple throwing of
a switch an electrostatic precipitator
goes to work to remove this public enemy
so that may be added to the harmless
mountain of smoke industry didn't build
this equipment sooner because it didn't
know how in fact it took over ten years
to develop and to build this plant near
Duquesne in Pittsburgh which just does
one job it removes Farrell manganese
dust and every day it builds this
mountain of smoke
even higher in just eight years built up
tell it by pellet this mountain has
grown until today it covers five acres
of ground and is 100 feet high all over
the country in fact all over the world
polluted air is a problem more and more
people are aware of it more and more
people are talking about it some people
are doing things about it among them a
dr. Leroy Bernie Surgeon General of the
Public Health Service US Department of
Health Education and Welfare air
pollution is a public health problem
nationwide in scope it is not limited to
any one cause or any single community
and his colleague dr. Richard PRNDL who
heads the air pollution medical program
of the Public Health Service air effect
your health we already have some of
these answers and Vernon McKenzie who is
in charge of the engineering side of the
servicemen's a service air pollution
program how does the air get polluted
and what can we do about it we have had
some answers to these questions too yes
the federal government is working on the
problem
but basically it is a local job one of
the pioneers in cleaning up the once
smoky city of Pittsburgh is dr. Edward
wide line retired president of the
Mellon Institute of the University of
Pittsburgh I first began to urge the
Pittsburgh there be cleaned up forty
five years ago after World War two it
became a tremendous team worked
operation with labour civic
organizations and city and county
governments all working together to
clean up pittsburgh share another
pollution fighter is s smith Griswold
air pollution control officer of Los
Angeles County the name of our public
enemy in Los Angeles is smog although
Los Angeles is a relative newcomer to
the air pollution problem we have a very
serious one and are working hard to
solve it
[Music]
this is Public Enemy the story of man
suffering from the byproduct of his own
progress the story of air pollution this
isn't a problem just for the experts
everybody causes it everybody can help
to with it
backyard incinerators and open rubbish
burning Factory emissions automobile
exhausts refinery chemicals and fumes
burning leaves and open burning dumps
those sources cars things like this to
happen in a community the problem of
clean air is a major one in many parts
of the country with the growth of our
cities and the parallel growth of
industry has come a brand new kind of
life a standard of living higher than
the past could even have dreamed of but
where you have progress you have
problems
air pollution affects almost everyone
and everything in eight principal ways
health effects irritation nuisance
soiling corrosion reduced visibility
damage to plants and damage to animals
the air over our cities can probably
never be returned to the purity of the
wide-open spaces to breathe this kind of
air we must travel ever-increasing
distances but we can make it fit to
breathe and keep it that way
Pittsburgh st. Louis and others have
pointed the way that they are winning
the first half of this air pollution
battle the fight against smoke one of
the reasons we've made this much
progress is because years ago a few men
recognized the dangers of air pollution
and decided to do something about it
dr. wide line I understand you began
fighting air pollution back in 1913
that's right
Pittsburgh was indeed a smoky city in
those days and it took a long hard fight
to change it many men had to change
shirts twice a day it was dark in the
middle of the afternoon
every building in town was ugly with
grime our problems in Pittsburgh was a
result of the fact that it's a heavily
industrialized area coupled with the
fact that the fuel used for heating was
soft cold well how did the Pittsburgh
got cleaned up by everybody working
together everybody helps some people
used to think that you had to have
smoking factory stacks to have full
paycheck but they learned otherwise and
joined the fight others said that
cleanup campaigns might raise prices but
they learned that it cost more to be
dirty than to be clean service clubs
church groups industry labor unions
everybody pitched in would you say that
the air pollution problem in Pittsburgh
has now been solved no it hasn't you
must understand that the contemporary
air problems involves a great deal more
than smoke chemical gases and even
metals our discharge into the air no
city has yet succeeded in controlling
those sources of pollution well I
realize that as I deal with the news
daily I continually run across items
about air pollution in more and more
cities it's obviously a national problem
dr. Bernie does the federal government
have any regulatory power in air
pollution no Carl as with many other
public health problems we believe that
the basic responsibility for control and
enforcement lies with state and local
agencies our job is to contribute to
research on problems that are national
in scope both in our own laboratories
and through grants to other institutions
and to assist states and communities by
providing technical assistance to them
and by helping to train air pollution
specialists well would you say dr.
Bonnie that air pollution is a major
health hazard in America today Carl we
are trying to find out how serious a
health hazard pollutions are in America
today we know that air pollution can
cause death under special circumstances
in Great Britain the medical profession
agrees that air pollution is a basic
cause of a condition called chronic
bronchitis which ranks third among
of death in England fortunately chronic
bronchitis is not a major problem here
but there is statistical evidence which
suggests that air pollution does have an
effect on health
you mean the breathing city air over a
period of time may be harmful yes we
know that there are toxic substances in
the air which in higher concentrations
can be harmful or fatal we know that
there are organic substances in the air
which act as irritants to membranes and
tissues and we know that people in
cities have a much higher death rate
from a number of diseases than people
living in the country I'm going to ask
dr. Richard Pindell who is in charge of
our air pollution medical program to
tell you about that the difference
between urban and non-urban death rates
for lung cancer cancer the digestive
system in our Terrace chlorotic heart
disease is pretty dramatic for example
out of every 100,000 people living on
farms and in small towns fewer than 15
will die of cancers in their spirit or a
system belongs the bronchus the trachea
but in big cities what happens the death
column rises about twice as many will
die of these diseases we get the same
kind of picture with cancer of the
stomach and esophagus and with heart
disease how do you blame air potion for
this not exclusively of course but it
seems like a likely suspect is a
contributing factor along with increased
strains accelerate tempo of life and
many other factors well I can see how
the kind of air you breathe might affect
your responder Tory system but why do
you think it affects the digestive
system and the heart we don't know
exactly what happens to the pollutants
when they get inside us but we know that
many air pollutants are swallowed the
possible relation to heart disease is
more indirect but it is possible at
irritants in the air caused changes in
the tissue of their spirit or e-track
these changes hamper breathing and this
in turn affects the heart the secretory
system I gather that most of the medical
research is an attempt to find out
whether the pollutants which man puts
into the air some of which we cannot
even see or smell stay in our system
building up gradually are causing
progressive damage slowly undermining
our health exactly we already know of
course that intense pollution can and
does kill this happened both in this
country and in Europe the onset of
intense fog holding pollutants which
settle like a pall over the community
when this happens people know it
doctors work around the clock hospitals
are filled deaths particularly among the
ages in the chronically ill increased
substantially but more often it happens
without people even realizing it for
example in London in 1952 there were
between 4,000 and 5,000 more deaths in a
single week than would normally occur it
was not until months later when death
records were analyzed in relation to
whether that Londoners became aware that
the intense smog which had bothered them
was actually a killer
well then a killer smog could happen to
any community at any time yes that is
one of the reasons why people need to be
aware of the dangers of intense
pollution if killer smaug's are
recognized early sources of pollution
can be temporarily reduced until the fog
lifts this way lives will be saved dr.
bernie is there any research underway to
help us find better quicker and cheaper
ways of cutting down air pollution yes
Carl actually a great deal particularly
in the engineering field one of the big
projects is the air sampling Network
which has been built up in communities
throughout the nation mr. McKinzie
can tell you about that and about some
of the other efforts that are being made
to find out what's in the air what
happens to it and how it can be better
controlled you actually sample area mr.
macKensie yes we are sampling the air
because before we can effectively keep
pollutants out of the air we have to
find out precisely what's in the air
consequently sampling stations have been
set up in all the states and territories
in about a hundred and twelve urban and
49 non urban sites they are operated by
volunteer agencies usually local health
departments using equipment furnished by
the Public Health Service dusts there
and non gaseous pollutants in the open
air are collected at these stations and
sent to our laboratories in Cincinnati
they're the sample is analyzed and at
3-month intervals the results of
analyses are given to the sampling
agencies for sampling suspended solids
this apparatus which is similar to the
conventional household vacuum cleaner
sucks a measured volume of air through a
filter over a 24-hour period
each of these samplers filter about
70,000 cubic feet of air through a sheet
of paper made of glass fibers liquid
droplets are filtered also and retained
along with the solid particles well why
don't the pollutants just blow away they
do sometimes Carl but whether or not the
pollutants blow away depends entirely on
the wind and other movements of the air
normally on a nice clear day the air
near the ground is warmer than that
higher up and less tends to rise and
carry the pollutants up with it
sometimes however the higher air is
hotter than that at the ground because
of a particular weather condition called
an inversion at such times the air near
the ground cannot rise and the
pollutants tend to accumulate just as
though there were a lid over the entire
area
inversion situations may persist for
several days has occurred this fall in
Los Angeles causing several smog alerts
people now people often get the idea
that an area must be surrounded by hills
or mountains which form a kind of
natural bowl for this inversion lid to
cover while a natural bowl formation
helps keep the pollutants close to the
ground
we don't need Hills or valleys around a
given area in order to have an inversion
an inversion can occur over a town
situated on the plains now that we're
learning more and more about what causes
pollution communities are better able to
deal with it let's find out what some of
them are doing about it let's go first
to Arnold arch a very important man in
air pollution control work he is
president of the Air Pollution Control
Association and director of the air
pollution control division for Niagara
Falls what do you have to tell us
the city of Niagara Falls New York has
long been known by the world as being
famous for its cataracts and as a resort
area for honeymooners Niagara Falls is
far more important as one of the most
heavily concentrated and diversified
industrial areas in the world the fame
of our industries is known the world
over it is not surprising that our air
pollution problems caused the city of
Niagara Falls to adopt the first
all-inclusive air pollution control
ordinance in New York State cooperation
will industry is the basic theme of our
program and it has certainly paid off
thanks Arnold and now to give us an
insight of the air pollution situation
in Detroit let's switch to Morton
sterling Air Pollution Control Officer
for the Motor City hello Carl
Shirley right in the middle of our new
multi-million dollar Civic Center as you
can guess there's going to be a lot of
white marble buildings located here and
we hope to keep them that way although
you can't see it in the scene right now
Windsor Canada is right across from us
across the Detroit River the
International aspects of our air
pollution problem are obvious and I
believe unique in this country we hope
to solve our transient ship smoke
problem through the International Joint
Commission this year and in Cincinnati
Charles Gruber is standing by to explain
their particular situation Cincinnati
has made excellent progress in dealing
with sources of visible air pollution
today we have 90 percent fewer smoking
chimneys than ten years ago
Cincinnati industries have also made
good progress in combating fly ash dust
fumes and odors we must see that our
community is informed and motivated to
action as technical progress points the
way to cleaner
fear outdoor air well let's pick up
another southern city again this time
we'll hear from Jacksonville Florida
where HD Peters is the division the head
of the director of the division of
sanitation and TB art is Assistant
sanitary engineer come in Jacksonville
yes chorim who injects people are
conscious of air pollution problems and
while a lot of the cute as in no highly
industrialized cities there do require
attention fortunately we know our
trouble spots and the good cooperation
are making progress towards control
orders are more concerned than smoke and
present more Venusian problem than
anything else
of course as such they should be kept to
a minimum
now let's sweep clear up to San
Francisco where Ben Winsky air pollution
control officer will tell us about their
novel arrangement under which six
counties and seventy communities are
cooperating to combat air pollution we
are standing here on quite tower on
telegraph hill in San Francisco I am
Benjamin Lenski air pollution control
officer in the San Francisco Bay Area
where we have recently started our
scientifically based air pollution
reduction and control program because
air pollution flows across political
boundaries we have merged six county
lines and seventy city limits into a
special government Control District no
other large community anywhere in the
world has ever yet has as clean an
atmosphere as its people really want we
believe we can do it in this great
Pacific Coast community by using the
best engineering and Community Program
methods developed in dozens of areas
here and abroad during the past 80 years
and now we'll hear from dr. Leonard
Greenberg Air Pollution Control
commissioner of New York City air
pollution is a byproduct to civilization
rather large groups of people live and
wait together
air pollution results in their daily
activity air pollution is produced by
heating equipment in our homes and
offices by industry by incinerators and
by automobiles we in the United States
have been slow to recognize the
importance of this problem and to move
against it
therefore air pollution is grown until
vigorous action is essential to our
health and well-being we must produce
air pollution and we must prevent the
development of new sources of air
pollution considered an intelligent
action now will be a benefit to all of
us probably the city I see most in the
news is Los Angeles oh you're coming
with a smog problem there mr. griswold
the problem in Los Angeles Carl is not
one of black smoke such as it is in many
eastern cities since coal is not used at
all we have a very complex problem of
gaseous pollution the characteristics of
which caused by irritation damage to
vegetation and a bluish gray pall which
held close to the ground by the
inversion reduces visibility the people
of Los Angeles have taken drastic action
to prohibit the use of incinerators or
open burning industry has been
controlled to a maximum that engineering
science will permit though the required
use of every known type of control
device many have been developed in Los
Angeles area
in fact industries which cannot control
air pollution cannot now locate within
the County of Los Angeles or it's 62
cities the major problem remaining is
connected with the use of petroleum
products in two different ways by Motor
Vehicles using gasoline and diesel oil
and by industry using fuel oil as a
source of its power when it is
recognized that we have the highest
concentration of automobiles per square
mile in the world as well as the
nation's third-largest industrial
complex then it must be understood that
the combination of these and our surface
inversions constitute a serious
community problem the Los Angeles County
Air Pollution Control Board headed by
supervisor Warren Dorn has adopted a
policy of requiring controls on every
source of pollution when a reasonable
method for such control exists
the board is holding public hearings on
a rule requiring Los Angeles industry
including their steam power plants to
burn natural gas in preference to fuel
oil during the seven months during which
smog is most likely to occur they are
Pollution Control District is testing
many devices for the control of
pollution from Motor Vehicles in its
automotive combustion laboratory when of
an effective device has been developed
its use will be required on the three
million automobiles operating on our
streets and highways well it's not only
dirt that bothers mrs. public in Los
Angeles and many other cities polluted
air causes physical discomfort too and
we have seen dr. Bernie some of the
functions being performed by the
engineering and medical divisions of the
Public Health Service air pollution
program well it seems to me that the
problem is getting worse rather than
better as you pointed out the more our
society grows the more air is being used
and polluted and the greater are the
demands on the air around us yes and we
have learned that air pollution and smog
are not only unpleasant but may have
definite harmful effects on the health
of the individual there is much to be
done about this growing problem and much
is being done for example in research in
addition to the extensive research
program of the Public Health Service a
great amount of research and analysis is
being conducted in research laboratories
and community air pollution districts in
the city county and state health
departments and by industry as we
indicated earlier the epidemiologic work
is a very important aspect of the work
being done this shows us the possible
relationship between air pollution and
such health problems is lung cancer
heart disease and stomach cancer
another very important activity as
described by mr. McKenzie is the air
sampling being done in more than 150
localities around the country this
national sampling network provides the
information communities need to attack
the problem on
local level everyday we are analyzing
these pollutants in our laboratories
ascertaining their content the extent of
pollution in the various communities
types of sources and other important
data which is needed in combating this
problem but the job doesn't end with the
medical engineering chemical and
sampling operations another important
phase is the education of individuals
concerned with the air pollution problem
and this includes a great many people
the United States Public Health Service
conducts an active training program
through which regular and frequent
courses are provided to air pollution
control people from all over the country
it is also important that people not
primarily involved with air pollution
control our research should know more
about this subject the better people in
all walks of life understand this
problem the better we will all be able
to deal with it an active program of
public information and public education
is therefore essential one method of
informing the general public for example
is through this program the Westinghouse
broadcasting company is performing a
fine public service in producing this
program as a means of helping inform the
public of the various aspects involved
in this very complicated and very
important problem the dissemination of
both technical and general information
is one of the reasons I called the
National Conference on air pollution in
Washington DC more than 900 people
including leaders of civic labor
industrial in many other groups in
addition to air pollution specialists
took part in this conference in November
1958 various research institutions and
local control districts including
several we have heard from on this
program sent exhibits to this conference
a complete aero metric station with the
most up-to-date equipment was set up and
put into actual operation on the grounds
of the Sheraton Park Hotel throughout
the sessions samples of Washington air
were taken on special filters which were
white when they went in blackened by
pollution when they came out conference
delegates spent a day hearing reports
from air pollution and
industry authorities technicians and
health officials they devoted the second
day to individual discussion groups and
on the third day heard reports of these
discussion groups followed by an open
forum question-and-answer session
we hope this conference will be one more
landmark in the long battle against air
pollution I hope it will be a turning
point some of that say 10 years from now
the people in every community will be
breathing air that is cleaner and more
wholesome we can reach that goal if we
all do our part well I certainly want to
thank you dr. Bernie for taking your
valuable time to come here today and
also for bringing dr. Pringle and mr.
McKenzie along with you we certainly
appreciate your efforts and of course
our special thanks to dr. wide line for
interrupting his retirement to bring the
benefit of his many years of experience
and certainly to mr. griswold for coming
to us from the west coast and telling us
of the problems of Los Angeles thank you
[Music]
Public Enemy the story of the byproduct
of man's progress air pollution was
directed by Jerry Lee
[Music]
and produced by Roger wolf
[Music]
your host has been Carl
eyes
[Music]
this program was presented in the public
interest by Westinghouse broadcasting
company in cooperation with the Public
Health Service of the US Department of
Health Education and Welfare
[Music]